hey what's up welcome back to our
channel my name's samuel and i'm amanda
and this week we're going to be
answering 10 of the most
popular questions that people like to
ask millionaires
and this is according to vice and
there's some very interesting questions
we haven't
we haven't gone through them yet i'm
i've told you the first one question but
there's ten
so we're going to go through them
together if you enjoy our channel please
do me a massive favor
and smash the like button subscribe so
you don't miss a future video
however before we get on to the 10
questions that apparently people have
always wanted to ask millionaires
what have you been up to this week this
week's been another good week it's been
really really busy actually
we started off with the crash course
this year are you saying that this week
you didn't just chill at home in the hot
tub with the kids yeah
keeping you guessing i've been at the
crash course and it's been so
fun to be back to the live events it's
just been like
i just love the atmosphere lots of
energy
it's been really fun it has it has we've
literally just
just finished a crash course which was
just incredible in london birmingham
swindon portsmouth and we're about to go
tomorrow is it tomorrow in to manchester
and then end in lee
yay
it was like i was like um you're from
leeds and that's my surname right this
is so meant to be and now i ask her name
so
all right great i've again pretend been
doing crash courses and also
trying to manage properties and refurbs
and
all kinds of stuff in between the crash
courses which has been fun
all right great so don't forget to
subscribe smash like why should why
should they like the video and why
should they subscribe
like and subscribe so you can see us
more and you know get to ask questions
as well don't forget to don't forget to
ask questions got questions
for us then ask and then we're gonna
we're gonna ask we're gonna answer 10
10 most popular questions that people
have always apparently wanted to watch
i ask millionaires but if there's more
questions that you have for us ask below
right first question i did give you a
tiny head about this question but this
is
how has having so much money
affected your personality
if i'm being honest it hasn't affected
my personality
at all uh if anything it's probably made
me
more generous because i feel like i have
more to give
but in terms of personality i don't
really think that money should change
you it definitely hasn't changed me
i think i'm literally just the same
person i remember when i went
on my little girls trip with andrea and
megan hi andrea if you're watching
but i think it was megan she said like
oh amanda like you really don't
like you're so wealthy but you really
don't like act a particular way you
don't use like particularly really
expensive makeup or anything like that
and i'm just like i think i'm just
really
humble and stupid you can't say
i'm really humble that's isn't that
humble thing to say
i am humble that or at least i feel like
i'm modest i'm not really so i feel like
my personality you wouldn't know that
i'm i'm i'm even more humble than a man
there is
i'm like the most humble person you'll
ever meet
no i think i think yeah you're
definitely humble um however
i'm gonna challenge you on this oh go on
didn't you tell me
what what are you gonna say what are you
gonna do didn't you tell me that you
when you like look back
because you went on a girls trip before
we we got married okay
and then you were like i feel like i've
like changed quite a bit like my
standards
okay my stance what happened to the same
the same place what happened
went back to the same place and i was
just what happened the first time
compared to the second time okay the
first time the first time i went on a
girl's trip to barcelona
and we were staying in this hotel really
really cheap and even like
the restaurants it was just like it was
everything was such a nightmare like oh
my gosh should we go there should we go
there
and like some of us were like oh no
that's too expensive some of us are like
you know it was just like
we were really scrimping and saving and
then the next time we went to barcelona
with samuel
we stayed at the w hotel which is like
really expensive really really snazzy
really nice
you know using taxis ubers left right
and center
not like caring how much you were
spending so it was i guess things have
changed in that way but i guess that's
not necessarily your personality it's
not personality
standards yeah standards you said to me
you were like i can't believe like
i think we walked past one of the hotels
yeah i believe i actually stayed there i
know
yeah i thought it was nice yeah yeah
standards changing standards have
changed for sure
yeah i think standards change
personality doesn't also
money doesn't change you it just exposes
who you really are
so if you are a nice humble person
like amanda it will make you more humble
and more nice
because you've got more money and more
freedom and like in all seriousness like
you're probably more chilled now than
you ever were
yeah because money brings
choice and freedom and relaxation yeah
but if you're a jerk
then you're going to be more of a jerk
yeah that's because so how
is money change would you do you think
money's changed my personality i don't
think so
to be honest i've always been a jerk
i think you've just you've always been
the same you've always been really
giving
always been really really giving and
yeah yeah that hasn't changed yeah you
know what and also russell says about me
as well russell says that i act like
an entrepreneur like demanding one
thing's fast
but i've always been like that even
before i had money in fact because i'm
like that that's why i have money
so all right cool next question okay
do men hit on you or women hit on me
just because we are wealthy
i haven't had that no i don't have women
hitting on me
i never have have women hitting on me
i've never had it i can't believe that
because look how handsome you i know
i've just
never had it i've never had women
hitting on me
um even since we've been married i've
never
had i wouldn't say never i've seen
someone hitting on samuel but it
literally just went over his head
so maybe people do but you don't even
realize because i don't think you're
you know you don't really i i don't know
but to me
i mean listen if maybe on instagram i
might go but but like in real life
um nope i've never had it i just don't
have women hitting on me
and even though i'm rich and good
looking
[Laughter]
you know i just i i just i think it
might be because i think you kind of get
what you
kind of i don't go look i've never i've
never gone i've always been so
focused on my business yeah i don't
think i don't think
i'd even have the time to like i don't i
don't just go
to you know where people like you might
just go to the club and hang and make
friends and
i don't do that i'm just like on
business if i'm at an event if i'm out
and about if you do stuff
i'm just so if anyone even i don't think
people would even be able to stop and
try they wouldn't get a chat they
wouldn't have the opportunity
um okay but yeah i mean
i see on the youtube videos you know the
youtube videos where it's like
oh you know this is me when i had my
rubbish car and [ __ ]
oh the golden sugar prank yeah and then
they get a big car and then suddenly all
these girls are coming over
yeah i don't think that's realistic i
think those videos are fake
i drive around 126 000 pound car very
nice car
i even once had any women
being like oh hi trying to make friends
because i'm in a nice car i mean i'm not
in a supercar
but i'm in a very expensive top of the
range range rover
i just think it's just baloney um i mean
i don't know what do you think yeah no i
totally agree i think that
it's stupid that someone would be
attracted to someone just because they
appear to have money like it's just
stupid and also the way that i am is
although i've got money i'm not like
super super flashy so i've got a nice
house i've got a nice car
you know i've got a very big business
got lots of stuff but i'm not like
going out and and splashing my cash
so i don't know i don't know
no nothing to add on that had men
hitting on you because of how rich you
are i think
i don't think it's because of how rich
you are i think i think it's other
reasons like how beautiful you are
okay are you jealous of people who have
more money than you no i'm not
i'm inspired by people if i see someone
that's really really wealthy i think oh
my gosh that's so cool i wonder how they
did that
i don't feel jealous by that i think
it's quite cool i don't feel jealous at
all like that
i sometimes i remember the first time
i ever i didn't even meet this person
but like i remember the first time
there's been a couple of people that
have had more money than me which is
fine
okay loads of people got more money than
me
richard branson's got way more like
loads of people right
but i made my money very
young i was a millionaire by 25. so i
didn't ever i never knew of anybody ever
that was making more money than me that
was the same age or younger
and i remember when i came across a
couple of people that were richer than
me and younger than me
and i gotta say it was a weird feeling
was it like
yeah yeah it was there was a um the guy
from gymshark
what's his name ben francis um and i
remember seeing jim shark take off and i
was like nice cool
and then i'm like damn this kid's
younger than me
he's now like richer than me this is not
a good feeling
it wasn't jealous but in terms of
everything else
like sports and academia and everything
i'm just like whatever you know whatever
but when it comes to making money i
pride myself on being
i'm the daddy at that tv so to see
and if someone's like twice my age and
they've got more money i'm like that's
fine because by the time i'm on their
age i'll be way richer
it's fine but when i came across the
kitchen gym shark
and then there was another kid um steven
stephen bartlett
you know steven bob yes i've heard of
him i gotta say i gotta say
because he's younger than me and i saw
him take off so successfully
and i was rooting for him and i'm like
yes great to see you but then when i'm
like damn this kid's younger than me and
richer than me
it was not a great feeling does it
motivate you then yeah you know it does
it does um but it's not jealousy
yeah i think it's more just like whoa
it's more like a fire under your ass
yeah
it's like whoa you know if someone's
younger than me and they've made more
money than me and i'm
i consider myself the best at making
money
you know i'll be like let's do a
financial freedom challenge face off
you know so so i guess to answer the
question i'm just being real real
yeah and i'm just trying to be real real
sorry are you jealous people have more
money than you no
but if they're younger than me and
they've made more money if they've
inherited it i don't mind
if they're inherited i'm just like okay
cool good for them if they've made it
from scratch and they're younger than me
and they've got more money than me
then it's like a fire under my ass it's
like damn
does that make sense yeah yeah it makes
sense okay cool maybe
that's how some people felt about me or
feel about me
and i guess you've got a choice when
that happens i could either try and
discredit those people
oh it's only because this this and this
oh it's oh jim shot that kid got lucky
right but that's being a hater yeah and
you know what you can only hate on
people that are doing better than you
so when someone's doing better than you
i don't have the opportunity to hate
very often because not many people do
better than me
but then it's like whoa am i going to be
a hater now
or am i going to be somebody that's
inspired you know yeah
okay cool are you worried about losing
your fortunes
um obviously you never know what the
future holds
but i almost kind of feel
this is me being real samuel's quite an
entrepreneur i think he just find a way
to like build it up again
so i think and you know you provide for
the family and stuff so
i think that i mean and i'd be happy if
we were living in this house or
in any other house as long as i'm with
my family for me anyway
so i'm not really that worried i mean
when covered hit
for example um we have a training
business there was no events
it's kind of like oh what's going to
happen but i think we survived through
that so i just
we did have to sell a lot of our
properties though yeah just again to be
really real
um our training business we we were
spending with our overheads and direct
costs we were spending 500 000
pounds half a million pounds a month
yeah
a month just on a training business
events staff technicians mentors
all the stuff and then suddenly our
training business
we don't take a salary out of the
training company but it's like
we're the owners of the company so if we
can't pay the staff what are we going to
do we're going to get rid of all the
staff this is before furl and everything
and
you know it was a bit of a worry yeah
it's like man are we gonna suddenly
stop you know and we did we sold we sold
off some of our houses
yeah some of them even at a loss because
we just needed to make sure that our
our staff and then happy business yeah
and as it happens you know um and we
we did and we kept all of our customers
people that joined our training programs
and stuff
we we gave them a service all through
the pandemic
um our staff we we were able now as it
happens furlough came in we didn't know
it was going to happen
um but like amanda i think a couple
things i'll say on on finances
uh is is number one um when you're an
entrepreneur
no matter what happens you're always
able to make money so it's not about
my fortune is not in my bank i see my
fortune is in my brain
more than anything and then the second
thing is
you need to be happy without as well so
i genuinely feel like we would actually
be quite happy if we just lived in
a small house and had a normal car and
you know because we've got each other
yeah and you know gary vaynerchuk talks
about perspective
um so if there was like i don't know if
there was a world war or something and
we ended up not being able to
live a good life a good quality of life
most important thing is family yeah um
so
i definitely can't say i lose sleep over
over losing money because i know i'll
just make it again or worst case if
something happens really bad like
there's a
holocaust or something terrible and
literally
the riches of the rich suddenly become
poor which has happened in history where
suddenly no one's got a good quality of
life
i just feel like it is what it is you
just got to be happy with what you've
got
count your blessings okay have you ever
bribed
anyone only when we're in like
zimbabwe oh what does that mean
the dodgy policeman that just stopped
you at the roadblock for no reason
so you've parented are you saying that
you have
bribed police officers no no okay
this is the this is like in zimbabwe
it's just the biggest
way or you can do what you want in
zimbabwe no but i'm just saying
sometimes they just stop you and then to
kind of get them off your back because
they would have stopped you for no
reason in the first place and they do it
on purpose so that they do get these
bribes because they're not
enough in the first place what i guess
what uh what's the definition of bribe
just because bribe i guess
is rush service a bribe if i'm saying to
my sister hurry up and get this over the
line and they go oh
sorry we're just a bit short stuff and i
got i'll give you an extra grand just do
it by friday
is that bribe fraction or is bribe
illegal
bro bro the definition of bribe is
dishonest persuasion
to acting on faith by gift of money um
okay
um oh but then there's another that's
the verb okay but the noun
is a sum of money or other inducement
offered or given
to bribe someone so okay so the second
one i've definitely done
so you've noun bribed someone but not
verb bribed someone
yeah well because the other way like for
example i don't know if i should talk
about this
about when um no no no it's here
tenants am i allowed to talk about that
uh yeah you are
it's like you don't want to talk about
it was perfectly legal so
we have i wanted some tenants to move
out of our property
and to get them out i bribed them yeah
and i basically just offered them some
money if they moved out by a certain
date
and that is perfectly legal and it was
like it's probably more of an incentive
wasn't it
incentive is the word yes so yeah i
guess
if you count that as like a bribe but i
was just incentivizing
but i think i think to be fair though
that type of
bribery which is totally legal bribery i
guess we do all the time
all the time because we'll pay for rush
service on stuff
or i'll say to the the physio that i
like the massage guy that only does half
an hour appointments you know
yeah yeah i want a triple session oh we
don't do triple sessions
money talks yeah that's true yeah i have
my triple session thank you
so much i think is that bribery was it
just paying people to do what you want
yeah you know i guess yeah we pay people
all the time to
do what we want we bribe you but it's
not bribe
it's incentivized yeah incentivized okay
do you pay your taxes
yes we do and it's a lot
it's a lot yeah it is i wasn't saying
numbers but my goodness yeah
it's actually not a lot in comparison
well i'm not very funny
but it's like some people don't earn
that much in a year
oh man yeah you're just talking about
our income tax yeah yeah like as a
company
yeah oh companies like like vat tax
and all the different national
insurances and different things it's
millions
however although we do pay a lot of
taxes
um i don't think we do pay a lot of
taxes in comparison
to how much we would pay if we were not
smart
okay if we were not smart oh my goodness
what you what do you think what do you
think we pay a lot of tax now
if we weren't smart we would pay like
way more than that yeah so um
yeah listen you know you have to pay
taxes
jim rohn says if you want to if you want
to
drive a car on the road and not drive it
in the dirt then you have to pay tax
you know we want to be able to use the
nhs and everything like that
and if taxes are right and fair however
there are a lot of
incentives from the government
where they let us off for example right
now what car are you getting
i haven't said yet but an electric
vehicle is what i'm getting
why are you getting an electric vehicle
because it's free yeah because it's free
because the government pay for it
effectively we don't pay for it we can
claim 100 of it back as
tax-free so that's an incentive is that
bribery
no it's an incentive okay next um why do
you think not everyone is as rich as you
are
i think i think it's just maybe people
not having the opportunities but
more so i think it's just people i think
it's just hard work really a lot of
people are not prepared to put in the
work
that it takes to be i think the biggest
thing is the risk
uh yeah we have money because i've
risked everything
yeah yeah yeah people won't take that
risk because they want a paycheck
they won't take the risk they won't
invest in themselves
they won't take the class
they won't work hard they want to do
what their friends do
i think a combination then follow the
sheep follow the system
there's a whole load of reasons why yeah
i think it's merely down to risk though
and putting in the work because you work
so hard and i don't think a lot of
people
are just willing to do that a lot and i
don't even have gratification and think
things come easy
i work hard though because it to me it's
normal because i did it for so many
years i don't even have to
i enjoy it yeah but yeah agreed
if you walk past a homeless person how
much do you give them
i never give them money i usually buy
them something
so yeah so yeah
so if you know what will you buy food or
i might ask them what they want
uh and then i'll go and get get it for
them so yeah i mean for me if i walk
past a homeless person
um i don't have a policy of i'll give i
won't give i'll give this much
you know some people say don't give
money to a homeless person because
they'll just spend it on drugs
some people say that's terrible why
would you not give me money to a
homeless person some people like amanda
go well i'll give them food
i don't think there's a right or wrong
answer we have our own charity that
we've set up which we put a lot of money
into which helps the homeless and helps
a lot of
different causes for me it's more about
whether i'm prompted sometimes i just
feel prompted
if i walk by somebody and when i say
prompted i'm more talking about whether
it be from
god or i just feel an intuition where
i'm like
i need to go sit with this person maybe
i'm not gonna give him any money maybe i
just need to go and sit with this person
for 20 minutes
maybe i need to give this person ten
pounds or five pounds sometimes we'll
shock people we'll go and give them over
like 100 pounds or something sometimes
you won't sometimes you might give
nothing i think you just you've just got
to
be attentive and have compassion
listen to your gut and intuition um
but but but it's really the whole issue
of giving like even when even when we
started doing
works in africa and stuff you've got to
be really careful because
there's a lot of people out there that
will try and scam you
and hundreds people will you know you've
seen the youtube videos where they'll be
homeless person begging
and then they'll they'll be home they'll
be legless but actually they're
pretending they've got no legs and then
they're like ha
and they're making loads of money it
does happen but then
you can be naive but then you can be so
naive that you just give and get scammed
but then you can also be so cynical that
you never give to anybody and i think i
think
you know it's what you've got to do is
you've actually just got to spend a
little bit of time researching how you
can best give
how you can best help and then do that
and that's what we've done isn't it
without
we put together a whole community in
zambia and stuff where we're like right
we're going to build some water wells
but we're going to do it properly yeah
we're going to partner with the
government
and we know that the money that we give
is actually helping yeah and going to
that cause
yeah also even these charities you know
you give like red nose day and stuff
you know i'm really sorry but a lot of
these charities you'll give money
and 90 of it will go
to the wages and the ceo's wages like
half a million pounds a year
some of these charities and then a
little bit of money that does go to the
people when you actually look at what it
does
um like i could tell so many stories
maybe maybe we should do another podcast
yeah
we'll talk about giving and you know
some of the stories of the schools the
orphanages the mosquito nets that
actually people have given but it's
devastated
it's devastated the villagers because
they've given with a good heart
but in a non-smart way if you'd like to
hear about that let me know comment
below and we'll talk about that
and that is the end so final words of
wisdom amanda leeds
final words of wisdom this week okay it
comes from
um one of my favorite books by grant
cardone
and it's just a quote so i'll just say
the quote the quote is
you'll not find the path to your purpose
in your comfort zone
so um saying that i'd say this week
going into the new week do something
that takes you out of your comfort zone
yeah you can't grow
while being in your comfort zone and if
you're not growing you're dying
heard it here first i hope you enjoyed
this podcast
don't forget ask a question comment like
subscribe and we'll see you guys next
time thanks for watching thanks for
watching guys bye